1400 $ pour chaque américain et ce n'est
peut être qu'un début
alors qu'aux états unis des millions
employés commencent à recevoir leurs
chèques financé par un plan de relance
massif à 1900 milliards de dollars les
européens ne voit toujours rien venir
annonce elle est annoncée l'été dernier
le plan de l'ue à 750 milliards d'euros
n'entrera en vigueur qu'à la fin de
cette année alors l'europe ont fait est
là c'est pour relancer son économie
n'arrive-t-elle pas trop tard par
rapport aux etats unis c'est l'objet de
l'édito échos ce soir bonsoir jacques
sapir comment expliquez vous cette
différence voir ce fossé entre le plan
de relance américain et son équivalent
européen
bonsoir c'est fanny et bien oui
effectivement c'est une différence qui
est très frappante à et la comparaison
d'une certaine manière elle fait mal
entre le plan que vient de faire voter
joe biden qui est un plan à 1900
milliards de dollars c'est à dire à peu
près 1600 milliards d'euros et le plan
de 750 milliards d'euros qui a été
décidé l'année dernière et qui n'est
toujours pas appliqué par l'union
européenne ajoutons à cela le fait que
évidemment le plan américain n'est pas
le premier n'est pas le seul plan il ya
eu d'autres plans avant qui ont été
faits par donald trump et ça bien
évidemment s'ajouter à toutes ces
différences alors il faut quand même
dire une chose c'est que le plan
européen vient s'ajouter quant à lui à
des différents plans nationaux parce que
les états ont fait une réponse nationale
en partie qu'une réponse budgétaire
national qui n'est pas négligeable mais
néanmoins quand on regarde l'ensemble
des filles quand on regarde le total des
chiffres
eh bien oui il ya une très forte
différence entre ce qui sera dépensé aux
états unis et ceux qui sera dépensé dans
les pays de l'union européenne
alors chacun qui est il exactement dans
ce plan américain alors ce plan dont de
1900 milliards ou de 1600 milliards
d'euros selon le calcul en euros mais il
comprend plusieurs choses on a tout
d'abord
d dz des aides qui sont versées à chaque
américain
on a après le paiement d'une allocation
supplémentaire pour les américains qui
sont au chômage
on a ensuite des déductions fiscales les
crédits d'impôts qui sont portés à 3000
$ pour les pour chaque enfant un entre 6
et 17 ans et pour les enfants en dessous
de 6 ans ces mêmes 3600 dollars et puis
on a différents autres aides des aides
aux collectivités locales et des aides
en particulier pour la réouverture des
écoles
bon tout ceci fait une masse d'argent
considérables on a dit un ça va faire
1900 milliards de dollars
ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
relève plutôt du soutien immédiat à
l'économie et il faut dire que les
ménages américains
on avait vraiment besoin parce que la
protection sociale aux états unis il
faut toujours s'en souvenir
elle n'est pas du tout au niveau de ce
qui existe en france en allemagne en
belgique en italie ou aux pays bas donc
c'est essentiellement un plan de soutien
de l'économie
et comment se situent les états unis par
rapport aux autres grands pays dans le
monde
alors je crois que c'est surtout sur
cette comparaison que l'on va toucher la
différence et je veux dire c'est cette
comparaison là qui nous fait mal quand
on regarde pourquoi et bien parce que on
va voir qu'en termes de mesures
budgétaires de contributions budgétaires
au soutien à l'économie les etats unis
ils sont quasiment à 26%
l'union européenne est à moins de 5%
la france est autour de 7% l'allemagne
qui est l'un des pays qui en a le plus
fait et à 11%
donc on est aujourd'hui confronté à
quelque chose qui est assez étonnant
c'est que ce sont les deux pays qui ont
la réputation d'être les plus libéraux
en est qu'un économie la grande bretagne
et les etats unis qui en ont fait
largement plus en terme de pib sous la
halle en termes de dépenses budgétaires
par rapport au pib que les pays
européens qui ont plutôt la réputation
d'être beaucoup plus sociaux démocrates
ou d'avoir développé un état providence
beaucoup plus fort même la grande
bretagne par exemple elle est au dessus
de sexe pour cent et on voit que ça
d'une certaine manière ça ridiculise un
petit peu les chiffres qui sont faits
dans l'union européenne en france en
italie et encore plus en espagne alors
cela veut dire finalement que les états
unis ont été plus touché par la pandémie
que l'union européenne vient non non et
c'est ça qui est aussi extrêmement
étonnant si vous voulez on sait que tous
les pays développés ont connu une
récession de l'ordre de 5% un petit peu
moins de 5%
et là dessus on voit que la récession
aux états unis elle a été relativement
faible comparée à la zone euro
nous avons une rose et une récession
globalement en termes de zone euro qui a
été plus de deux fois supérieur moins
7,2 pour cent contre -3 1% pour les
états unis et en plus en france on est à
moins 8,3 en italie on est à moins 9 6%
bon pourquoi est ce que les états unis
ont d'une certaine manière moins
souffert des conséquences économiques de
la pandémie
mais il ya plusieurs raisons à cela la
raison principale étant quand même la
taille du pays et le fait que jamais les
états unis n'ont été globalement fermé
si vous voulez on a eu on a toujours des
situations de confinement dans certains
états sur certaines agglomérations par
exemple new york qui est encore
aujourd'hui très largement confiné mais
à côté de ça vous avez d'autres états où
on travaille normalement
donc cela a quand même beaucoup
contribué à réduire
je dirais le choc économique de la
pandémie jacques on en vient maintenant
aux plans de relance européens dont on
parlait ou est il donc passé
et oui ma soeur stéphanie que voyez-vous
venir vous connaissez la formule
alors il faut se rappeler une chose ce
plan il a été décidé en juillet 2020 il
a été ratifié en décembre 2020 on nous
annonce aujourd'hui au mieux qu'il
rentrerait en action cet été c'est à
dire avec douze mois de retard par
rapport à la décision est en réalité on
s'attend plutôt à ce qu'ils rentrent en
action à la fin de l'automne au début de
l'hiver donc entre 15 et 18 mois après
la décision
alors pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
pris un tel retard alors d'abord il ya
des choses qui sont liées aux procédures
européennes
c'est un plan de l'union européenne et
ça veut donc dire que tous les pays de
l'union européenne doivent voter les
mesures du plan et ça ça va prendre du
temps parce qu'il ya toute une série de
pays qui ont des désaccords et où il va
falloir d'une certaine manière
convaincre les oppositions ça c'est un
premier point deuxième point
eh bien c'est la commission européenne
qui en est responsable parce que la
commission européenne elle demande à
regarder très précisément ce qu'elle va
financer et si ce que les pays ont
décidé de financer ne correspond pas aux
priorités de la commission européenne
elle refuse en tous les cas elle
provoque un mécanisme si vous voulez
qu'on rediscute avec les gouvernements
tout ceci prend du temps et puis il ya
une troisième raison une raison et qui
peut-être n'ont vite et bien c'est le
fait que il va y avoir des élections à
la fin de l'année en allemagne aura nous
avons tous des élections très importante
en france l élection présidentielle
l'année prochaine peut-être que le
gouvernement français comme le
gouvernement allemand cherche à retarder
l'entrée en action de ce plan de manière
à pouvoir dire si vous voulez vous au
moment des élections
voilà l'argent européen vient vous voyez
c'est l'union européenne qui nous
protègent non ajoutons à cela une chose
c'est que ces 750 milliards d'euros ils
doivent être dépensés au mieux
sur deux ans et plus de manière plus
raisonnable sur quatre ans donc on n'est
pas du tout au niveau du plan de relance
américain
mais les montants de ces plans européens
et américains jacques sont ils
comparables finalement non non
absolument pas alors rappelons l'union
européenne c'est 457 millions
d'habitants pour ces 457 millions
d'habitants nous avons donc 750
milliards d'euros ça nous fait à peu
près 1000 1600 euros par habitant aux
états unis nous avons 1600 milliards
pour 328 millions d'habitants est alors
si on rapporte évidemment à l'ensemble
des mesures de soutien budgétaire
la différence est encore plus en notre
défaveur
les etats-unis ont dépensé depuis mars
2020 c'est-à-dire sur un an
grosso modo maintenant sur 13 mois ils
ont dépensé 14 1140 euros par habitant
alors que nous n'avons dépenses et nous
que en france que 2500 70 euros les
allemands qu'ils 33 l'italie 1737 la
belgique 3000 euros donc il y a là aussi
une énorme différence alors bien sûr on
dira les pays européens ont plus recouru
à des mesures d'ordre monétaire
mais ces mesures d'ordre monétaire c'est
la banque centrale européenne
en réalité qui les a rendues possibles
et puis qu'est ce qu'elles aboutissent à
quoi mais n'aboutissent tout simplement
à accroître l'endettement l'endettement
des entreprises d'endettement des
ménages
c'est pas du tout une bonne solution et
on voit là que les états unis ils ont
pris un temps d'avancé considérable par
rapport à ce que l'on fait en europe
et justement quelles conséquences alors
la conséquence pour le voit déjà aux
états unis c'est que l'économie
américaine
elle redémarre même si la pandémie est
très loin d'être réglée aux états unis
si vous
les tout le monde le sait tout le monde
sait qu'il ya toujours d'énormes
problèmes sanitaires bien sûr les états
unis sont aussi très en avance sur nous
sur la vaccination
là non plus il n'y a pas photo comme
comme on dit mais globalement l'économie
redémarre alors ça se voit sur
différents chiffres ça se voit en
particulier sur les dépenses de
construction qui ont littéralement bondi
qui ont explosé d'ailleurs ça pose
aujourd'hui des problèmes en europe et
en france ça fait monter le prix de tous
les matériaux de construction et du bois
pourquoi parce que la demande
aujourd'hui en moins de construction des
états unis est telle qu'elle est en
train de saturer le marché
et puis il ya d'autres chiffres qui sont
extrêmement intéressants et qui montre
que très probablement les états unis ne
revint jamais été les retrouveront leurs
niveaux de production d'avant la crise
sanitaire vers la fin de cette année
voir la fin de l'automne pour ce qui est
de l'union européenne et en admettant
que la campagne vaccinale se passe comme
prévu ce qui vous le savez est loin
d'être gagné et bien ce serait plutôt à
la fin 2022
donc là encore on voit bien que l'union
européenne a pris un an de retard sur
les etats-unis l'union européenne a pu
dire tout ce qu'elle voulait sur la
mauvaise politique de travaux sur la
politique des américains même de joe
biden qui n'étaient pas adéquates face à
la pandémie
la réalité elle est là nous avons pris
un an de retard dans notre réponse face
à la crise
et ça ça va jouer parce qu'on voit bien
que l'europe elle est en train de
décrocher
elle décroche et ça je vous l'avais déjà
dit par rapport à la chine et à l'asie
du sud-est c'était évident mais ce qui
est nouveau aujourd'hui
est ce que l'on voit de plus en plus
dans les chiffres économiques c'est
qu'elle décroche aussi très nettement
par rapport aux états unis alors jacques
que faudrait il faire bien ce que l'on
voit c'est que aujourd'hui il faut d'une
certaine manière de la flexibilité il
faut peut-être mettre de côté ce cadre
de l'union européenne qui par sa
bureaucratie par les compromis qui sont
nécessaires au sein des 27 pays qui nous
tire en arrière qui est en train de
plomber littéralement l'économie
l'économie de la france mais aussi
globalement l'économie des pays de
l'union européenne il est temps et ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose dont on
est tous en train de prendre conscience
et qu'il jouera évidemment un rôle
extrêmement important lors de la
prochaine élection présidentielle
il est temps de renationaliser nos
politiques économiques
on voit bien que l'union européenne
n'est pas capable de faire ce pour quoi
elle a été créée